dust your floors the cutest way possible
with a fuzzy robot cleaning ball and
protect your banana from bruising thanks
to the banana bunker because it's
episode 52 of loose skate through the
day on the most advanced electronic
skateboard in the world the marble board
is controlled with an app reaches a top
speed of 25 miles per hour and goes 16
miles before needing a recharge use the
app to set your speed and adjust the
rate of acceleration so once you hop on
the board there won't be any surprises
if you want a scientific surprise simply
subscribe to groovy lab in a box a
monthly collection of hands-on science
fun to promote stem learning and tap
into your inner engineer tap into a
watermelon for some fruity beverage
dispensing fun using the watermelon keg
and stay professionally dry in the water
while wearing the Quicksilver true
wetsuit the waterproof business suit
comes in black navy or tuxedo and is
accompanied by a waterproof shirt and
tie keep it business in the front while
partying in the back thanks to the
instant mullet headband then start your
own mechanical band with mr. na key the
drumming robot hold the drumsticks and
start roaming and mr. na key will mimic
your movements don't knock fishing until
you've tried it with the fish catching
RC boat that comes with pre rigs tackle
and it can catch up to a 2 pound fish to
help catch some Z's there's the wakeup
light alarm clock it lulls you to sleep
with its sunset simulation and gradually
wakes you with birds chirping and the
sunrise arcade resurrection allows
pinball machines to rise from the grave
altar furniture completely tears down
discarded pinball cabinets and
repurposes the artwork and parts to
create incredible tables like Star Wars
pinball becoming the Droid coffee table
or the 1987 game arena transforming into
the Beast one of the beast ways to
impress your friends is turning objects
invisible the invisibility kit is
comprised of a series of convex lenses
and metal rods which can remove small
objects from sight sight
your farmer on your list of
accomplishments after you grow
everything you need with the grow your
own beer garden they guarantee the
plants will grow and you get to house it
all in a see-through dome making it the
beer of the future
flight into the future with these
sidewinding circular skates that give
you the ability to make sharp turns and
perform tricks all while sidewinding
like a snake if butterflies are more
your spirit animal these butterfly
keychains will speak your language
but if butterfly is the only language
you know the 15 language talking
translator can help you communicate and
even includes a calculator for
converting euros you're also going to
love movies are fun a picture book that
draws scenes from r-rated movies in a
cartoony pixar style including classic
moments from pulp fiction The Godfather
and my personal favorite The Big
Lebowski now you just need a rug to tie
the room together like this latch hook
Lebowski whether or not you like it is
just like your opinion man borrow Soros
the football with the dinosaur quiz
borrowing the amazing brick aesthetic of
Lego is the lego computer the specs are
listed on the website its customizable
and designed for future expansion and
you can purchase one of three designs
industrial brick or tile tiles of
letting other people build things for
you design and program your own hexapod
6 you get 3d print a number of open
source parts for the robot and even
connect it to your smartphone I'm afraid
our time is coming to a close so fill a
personalized mason jar from personal
creations comm with some kimchi flavored
soda and if you don't like the taste
don't worry I won't be offended in fact
zero Fox given and as always thanks for
watching
you